Our dad told us all these
stories about growing up here
tell you it sucks actually
i think he kind of loved it
but we came here as a family it's too
dangerous for them to know it's more
My name is todd helbing executive producer
on superman and lois more juice great thing
about this version of superman and lois lane and
lana lang is that they're all parents your place
in the fridge jonathan's got some news and
apologize to jordan you missed therapy today
not only are these heroes as relatable as
they've ever been all the heart and humor
you'd expect in a family drama inherently exists
in spades you got a minute boss won't fire you
was it always this hard for you and dad
from financial troubles to mental health
issues to finding the right life work balance is
something every parent in the world can relate to
feels like it's my fault that
this is all falling apart
we hit almost every major touchstone that's
been seen in the superman series and films
but approach them all through a new lens
to give these stories a fresh new look
we've approached the vfx in a new way
that will bring the vfx to the next level
in this show the family units which
is the kent as well as the cushings
50 yards and approaching these families are really
the story engines and focus of the first season
they're not just characters
they're people we all know and love
I haven't always been there for you i will be and
we're all excited for everyone to meet them soon
when we were dreaming about having a
family didn't look like this did it
superman and lois two-hour premiere
event tuesday february 23rd
stream free next day only on the cw app
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is gonna
be my new Superman trailer from the super bowl
this past weekend there's a new justice league
snyder cut teaser trailer that i'll talk about
as well so if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
i'll talk about the new justice league snyder
cut teaser trailer footage then i'll talk about
the superman episode 1 footage so here's
that new justice league snyder cut trailer
you said the age of heroes would never come again
it will it has to
we live in a society where honor is
a distant memory isn't that right
batman so there's a whole lot of stuff going on
in that obviously it looks very different from the
theatrical cut it's gonna feel very different zack
snyder the way he's talked about it in previous
years i think the theatrical cut only wound up
using a small percentage of the footage that he
originally shot so the actual snyder cut itself
even though technically it's kind of the same
movie is really a completely different movie but
it feels relevant that they opened the trailer
with that superman flashback scene to batman
v superman when he's screaming creating those
shock waves in lex luthor's voiceovers talking
about the bell being rung steppenwolf and darkseid
being alerted making their play to come back and
steal the mother boxes so they can take over the
earth so there's going to be a whole bunch of
superman related stuff happening in the next
month because we have the superman tv show that's
premiering next week actually as i'm posting this
video and then the snyder cut within a couple
weeks of that the really big things that you
do not see in that snyder cut trailer though are
martian manhunter harry lennox actually is martian
manhunter they added that back in i don't know
if he originally had plans to put that in his
version of the theatrical cup before he left the
project but there are storyboards that go way back
so it sounds like he did have some kind of plans
for a version of martian manhunter at some point
they said the way they accomplished him was
through motion capture so i believe some of
the new martian manhunter stuff was done in the
justice league additional photography that they
did late last year i'll talk about this in
a second when i talk about the batman and
the joker scenes because that's obviously the
other biggest thing in the trailer the biggest
reveal is that jared leto's joker shows up in the
nightmare sequence with batman and it's almost
like they put their past behind them because the
earth has basically been laying waste by darkseid
it'll be fun to talk about all the crazy time
travel stuff that's happening during that because
they were originally laying that seed back during
batman v superman and it was originally going
to be paid off in the justice league sequels
but now there's only one justice league movie
so because zack snyder is adding all this extra
stuff into the franken movie version of the
justice league snyder cut a lot of people are also
expecting him to beef up the nightmare sequences
in the time travel stuff so that he can pay that
off because there isn't going to be a sequel
as far as we know right now at least zack snyder
says that warner brothers doesn't have plans for a
sequel to his justice league movie never say never
there's always a chance that he could come back
and do an hbo max series with some of the justice
league characters all the extra dark side stuff is
looking great some of the dark side stuff you see
him in his full costume and it looks like he has
the omega force like he's become full-blown dark
side and i believe that's probably gonna be from
the nightmare timeline which is like the alternate
post-apocalyptic future all the dark side war
flashback stuff you notice is different because
he doesn't have his armor on but you do see the
omega symbol sort of embedded in his chest upside
down i believe that's when he's still supposed to
be ooxus before he's taken the name darkseid and
taken the omega force the whole jack kirby history
of the new gods in the forces of apocalypse is
very game of thronesy so hopefully they'll address
some of that when they eventually do the new gods
movie that they're actually working on right now
but that movie will be a little bit different
and then it's more based on the tom king mr
miracle run which is a very different way to tell
a new god story so i'll just talk more about that
when they eventually start dropping previews it's
still going to be a couple years away so it'll be
a while before we actually see footage for it
then this really badass looking scene of black
suit superman going all ham on someone with his
heat vision i'm assuming is from the final battle
with steppenwolf and this is steppenwolf that he's
attacking the whole explanation behind the black
suit is just fascinating from a technical level
but also on a story level as well zack snyder said
the studio originally was so against him doing the
black suit but he wanted to do it so badly that
what he did when they were filming all of henry
cavill's scenes before he left the project is
they filmed him in the regular blue suit and then
he just found a way to photoshop it effectively
it was way more complicated than that i'm kind of
simplifying it but effectively they photoshopped
the blue suit black in post-production so that
he could show the studio how cool it looked
and if they ever said yes he could basically just
click a couple buttons and turn it black when the
movie was done now that they're letting him do
whatever they wanted to with the project obviously
it's going to be black during the movie but when
you're watching the movie and you see superman
flying around in the black suit you're actually
watching him in the blue suit it's just been made
to look black in post-production then there's the
new preview that he released of the joker that's
right jared leto's joker filmed new scenes for the
justice league snyder cut during the reshoots that
they did a little while ago or the additional
photography however you want to think about it
technically it's additional photography based on
what he said recently it sounds like he originally
had plans for more joker in future movies but i
believe the new joker stuff with the older version
of jared leto's version of the joker is meant to
address the dead robin storyline from way back in
batman v superman remember that was supposed to
be dick grayson there was a lot of confusion when
the movie first came out but i believe the idea
is this scene with this version of the joker is
meant to happen in that alternate post-apocalyptic
future like the nightmare timeline where darkseid
has taken over the earth and enslaves superman
using the anti-life equation the joker and batman
will share scenes but it's the nightmare batman
with the older version of the joker but because
of all the craziness that's happened with darkseid
taking over the earth and so much time going by
their relationship has fundamentally changed a lot
but if you were wondering the jared leto stuffed
the scenes for the justice league snyder cut that
was all new stuff that they did last year way back
in zack snyder's original version of the movie
from years ago there was no jared leto joker in
there then just moving to all the new superman
trailer footage from the super bowl we get more
scenes of him with his twin sons john kent and
jordan elliott ken named for his two different
fathers john kent and jor l they actually just
announced their new version of jorel for the
series he's going to be played by this actor who
you probably recognize from some movie or tv show
he's been in a billion different things there's
a bunch more footage of them going down into the
basement of the barn to look at his kryptonian
ship and then some more context for how his twin
sons find out that they have powers as well it
sounds like they get into some big fight in the
bar and there's a huge accident but they don't
get hurt and that's when he has to reveal to
them oh the reason why you're not hurt now the
reason why you didn't get crushed is because
you have special powers because you're my sons
and i just happen to be the most powerful being
on planet earth they also try to hype up the new
way they did their visual effects for the series
trying to take it next level from what you're used
to in the arrowverse people always clown on the
special effects from the aeroverse shows like the
supergirl tv show even some of the special effects
on the flash look kind of like ps2 graphics at
points but a lot of the creative behind the new
superman tv show is meant to take it to next
level which is why it seems so much like the
man of steel movie the way they explain it the
entire series all the episodes will be in movie
aspect ratio most of the disney plus series like
the mandalorian star wars series or the falcon
and winter soldier marvel series those are all
in movie aspect ratio as well it's just meant
to make it feel more cinematic more like you're
watching a really long movie broken up into pieces
but because it's a superman obviously
they're going for more man of steel energy
they hype up that most of season one is based
around what's going on with lana lang's family
because she has a daughter that has some sort
of relationship with superman's sons i don't
know if there's going to be a love triangle there
or something like that they kind of imply that's
the case the funeral that they have during the
trailer seems like it's probably going to be
for his mother martha ken because they talked
about losing both of their parents too soon
with the exception of general sam lane obviously
lois's father they've recast the actor i've talked
about him in the previous trailer videos i've
done for this but the big change it seems like
they made with his character is that he knows
superman's secret identity he knows that clark
kent is superman which is not the case in previous
series or even in the previous pre-crisis on
infinite earth's timeline for the arrowverse we'll
probably see more recast versions of characters
from the superman comics that they've already used
on supergirl but they're using crisis on infinite
earth as an excuse to reboot and just re-tune
everything about the creative and the characters
i don't know if they're gonna have melissa's
supergirl character cameo during season one
or show up in an episode diggle is gonna show
up and they'll probably do some diggle green
lantern stuff i'll do an episode one video
when that releases and we'll just see how
everybody feels about the show before
i commit to doing every single episode
but everyone post all your reactions in the
comments below and just big reminder my full
one division episode 7 video will post friday and
then my superman video next tuesday everyone click
here for my full justice league snyder cut trailer
video and click here for my one division episode 7
trailer video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!